shei and irving joins us after the
Cowboys impressive performance in
Atlanta high-tech hey Danny
hey but one thing Danny yeah one
overarching thing that I've been calling
about forever in the day the Ivy League
ginger is the worst head coach in
professional football in America or
across the pond or wherever the hell
they get paid to coach a game called
football this man is the worst at it
Chaz Green was getting beat like yo clay
more money and it wasn't a single
solitary adjustment made by that stupid
ginger or his worthless coaching staff
this loser got named coach of the year
last year Danny last year and this is
the crap he put out there how the hell
do you not make a single adjustment how
the hell do not have a running back come
off the end of chip him or help him or
somehow do anything because Chad dreams
of getting beat so bad how Danny
explained that I said the same thing as
I'm watching after the third sack I went
is somebody going to put somebody over
there just to chip this guy slow him
down because if not dak Prescott has no
time whatsoever didn't understand it at
all Doku worried about a trivial pursuit
or some crap it wouldn't even watch the
damn football game everybody saw that
crap Danny I know and you and all these
other people don't understand how bad he
is at his job it I just it blows my mind
Danny why is he getting paid besides
being the puppet for Gerald Jones that's
the only reason I think I think we can
all admit that you can say right here
live on that radio well I think that
that's happened before where Jerry puts
in somebody that he can control because
he wants to be owner coach and GM
speaking to him being a general manager
Shawn Lee injured again you saw what
happened with the defense maybe just
maybe if I'm a general manager I'm gonna
draft somebody that's gonna take the
reins from Shawn Lee who has actual
working nerve endings and it's freakin
legs instead of Jaylon Smith huh you got
the Eagles coming to town God Jesus
Christ Danny you gotta bring up that
massacre it's gonna happen next week
speaking of gingers damn it that one's
gonna tear us in half
Carson wins ah and good for a long time
Danny day it ain't good anything don't
look good for the Ivy League ginger and
the rest of them
not at all you lost your bet to the
front row as well well here we go here
we go
you had it Paul you had army in the
under yeah against Duke yeah
parlez ma'am where do you guys stand
with this what yeah you did you did
where do you guys stand on this bat
calling I'm gonna need a calculator I'm
that K I'm not gonna calculating parlays
okay carry the one all right so the
Cowboys aren't making the playoffs right
didn't you say that last week I told you
okay all right call me Miss Cleo over
here I didn't know was gonna go down
like this I didn't know that they would
let jazz green die on an isolated corner
I didn't know that was how they were a
loose daddy I just knew one good look
great yeah but like you can't be Miss
Cleo if you're missing all these other
games that you're predicting so all
right you know the Cowboys aren't gonna
make the playoffs how about you predict
a good football you know
okay that was me that was me that was
just I was thinking that and on those
words laughter now I am wearing pain I'm
trying to take your mind off of the
ginger well you're never gonna do that
alright well we'll see you on Friday
it'll be great can't whatever Danny
that's a nervy for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]